[music]
dero open to
dowake
render globe walker
gps are
you
doing
voodoostare
arap prop
baren r
perat zuu spe
play ome zuu
strea a
this over the prize
Arthur's action robe
onodera leander zare
spruce  are you doing
voodoothe voodoo
mong
androd carming free to
do you were to
do
voodoo far just
forever Cats with the
good the main
floor does berth
pou
dou
douusa deemo the
voodoo
2 turn to do for
someone you gon deep
moa peace coder
ahkah zu foam den pearl x
close
dense ason pack mar d
3 e 02 nd 2 see
some work to do
air
ano fahren
ducale dee
up screen foam
da that hazard is a shock point
prime  order figure
frente to
do
voodoothe voodoo smooth
chas 8 part pure do
do
worth to do nodera
ganbare ng clan to
see a re mi peace to
do
[music]